this is a rapidly becoming very ugly it
is this isn't looking good this seems to
be the hot spot right here the two fires
began within a day or two of each other
this is huge because this is a big state
and it's on fire in the north and in the
south
the scale and the speed of this
particular wildfire took everybody by
surprise
oh my god you stupid let me die
[Applause]
huge numbers of fire personnel involved
in trying to put out the flames all the
firefighters we spoke to spoke about the
unprecedented nature of this fire the
speed and the ferocity of the flames
it was roaring through California it I
mean it was so fast have rain for you
know best part of a year and it was the
perfect storm Bertha thioester
old values on fire no one had ever seen
fires moving this fast so ferociously it
was raging through there
you wouldn't be able to out drive that
kind of stuff the imagery that we
started to see was almost impossible to
compute there's definitely burning on
all sides of us any father please help
us please help us to be safe
all of them say it was absolutely
terrifying few of them thought that they
were going to get out of life many many
didn't the embers were one of the
biggest concerns of the firefighters
traditional walls of flames they can be
stopped
you can drop water you can drop
retardant upon them but when the embers
are flying on a wind the fires start in
front of you behind you to the left and
to the right and so there's nothing much
the firefighters can do
the evacuation plans which were really
well organized the reality was that as
soon as a really big one happened all of
the plans fell apart because there
wasn't enough time
when we initially arrived in Los Angeles
the fire was still active
everybody concentrated their coverage on
that of you because there's so many big
names you know who'd evacuated actors
actresses pop stars etc we stopped on on
the beach to look at this humongous
cloud billowing out over the sea and
basically cutting out the Sun so you
could smell the smoke you could see it's
kind of eerie
I guess potential station is open I were
letting us through there will very much
be careful this is an active fire we
can't help you if you get in danger we
wanted to see the damage that this
particular one in Malibu had caused and
you know so we kept going we saw the big
flames come over the mountains and they
were just tornadoes fire
what really strikes you is the
randomness of the firestorm this house
is in really good condition in fact it's
barely been touched we're in Malibu one
of the richest areas of this part of
California this is a beautiful house at
least it was come up to the front door
though you'll see that absolutely
nothing is left completely and utterly
destroyed and this house was worth
millions and millions of dollars
we're hearing lots of flare-ups is that
where you're having a fight at the
moment we're preparing for that so we're
trying to mop up these best we can
before it gets windy right and their job
was to go and make sure that the fire
didn't start again
they got gas is on fire here everything
in me is like get the hell away from
there right if it wasn't burning I'd be
worried that it ignite and I could hurt
the captain in charge of the of the
engine company took out a cell phone and
said well yeah have a look at this
everything Wow and the winds were going
fast as well oh yeah
the fire was really raging through that
part of Malibu they haven't seen
anything so intense so much explosive
capacity
and they say that just go to a point
where actually the fire was so ferocious
it was raging at such a high speed that
even they had to pull back
we met Kari have some goat milk if you
want turns out that she is an organic
farmer a no-kill character does high-end
organic farming for big restaurant
chains she showed us where the flames
came through once it hit that big
beautiful tree right there yeah that was
it
and then it just kept on there yeah she
showed us a picture of herself standing
on top of her farmhouse with a hose pipe
trying to fight off the flame was that
just like a wall of fire coming towards
you and then the wind twisted towards
the beach this way then it just started
off we were writing this the farm had
survived but her home had not shouldn't
have anywhere to stay
this is what life is change and we hate
change generally but what are you gonna
do I mean it's just things I didn't we
were we're safe every blessed
she sort of refused to be a victim she
was already mentally rebuilding her life
it's a big change and it's a new
beginning I can only do what I can do
and I'm not gonna get upset about you
know 50 50 years worth of stuff people
had died in the fires and really she was
just feeling grateful that it was just
her home that was gone something that
can be rebuilt and she was very much
under the impression that Malibu we'll
bounce back no problems here you know
we'll just get back to business just as
soon as the fires contained the news
desk says that we need you to go north
in Paradise in Northern California and
the surrounding communities not much was
known about what had happened there at
that station nobody knew how bad
paradise was people hadn't really been
there but the death toll was certainly
rising
oh my god and you're starting to see
it's personal videos of getting out move
people
flames engulfing highways what are you
waiting for go go go go oh my god oh my
god by fire seeing people getting out
but what's it like way inside what's
left in the early hours of the morning
we got in our vehicle and decided to
drive there about two hours out the Sun
started to go at that point I was a
little ignorant as to what we're about
to see I just looked down on the set now
it's displaying the smoke forests on
that and the closer we got to paradise
the quieter it became we knew we'd
reached the outskirts when we looked
left and we looked right you notice that
the fields all around you I mean mile
after mile the fields were blackened we
drove through a sort of hillside and
came up and down and there was a
humongous valley that obviously been a
forest and it was just completely
charred wagon
it was apocalyptic
then I realized that as you were driving
along what appeared to be like a forest
wasn't a housing estate but there were
just no houses left
you could see abandoned cars inside the
road
[Music]
we actually had to turn around go back
and drive again just to make sure we had
just seen what we had just seen the cars
lined up on the side of the road
potentially all just coffins sitting
there all of us in the car was a speech
system we entered paradise and there was
complete silence all of us were staring
out the window going what it was as if
life cease to exist there it was
actually impossible to even imagine that
human beings had lived there just two
days earlier
I said to the guys listen this is a
massive story and that needs to be what
we focus on it's just unbelievable but
you've got to get that out as quickly as
possible
the figures we had four deaths was
really quite small at that stage and we
were looking and talking to an RN saying
that you you know those figures can't be
right
[Music]
the reality of the high number of deaths
there became apparent when you'd see
cars on the side of the road with either
a ribbon
oi X spray-painted honored to indicate
that the vehicle had been checked and
whether a body had been found or not it
was clear that this fire moved so fast
on was so complete was it is like a bit
of town it was all of it the level of
destruction here is simply remarkable
this is somebody's home as you can see
the bike everything's been abandoned
this is the the living room very likely
and now coming outside the house and
going next door again absolutely nothing
left whatsoever the only thing still
standing the fireplaces though the only
things that were made of brick so when
the fire came everything in this area
just went up in flames this is a lot of
people used to live here is a utterly
destroyed it must have been absolutely
terrifying when the fire struck everyone
we spoke to who lived in Paradise you
know before the fires spoke of it as
this idyllic serene hillside community
[Music]
so we're driving around into the town
and we see to the sheriff's department
local police officers who were advising
search and rescue to see if there was
any fire still whether there was anyone
alive I know in every street right now
they checking what houses are standing
they're coming back to us and report
they definitely seemed somewhat shocked
they said you know it's it's heaven
unless it's probably the worst thing
I've seen definitely the most
devastating incident we've encountered
since we've been on ever yeah they were
trying to get people out they were
trying to get people down the main road
which I think it's called ask Iowa when
everyone realized I had to go they all
left at the same time yes and then the
streets were clogged we did the best to
open up all the lanes burn down Skyway
and they knew people couldn't get out
they used to use themselves they would
potentially in danger we're battling the
fire getting to the streets and
it says even as you're trying to get
people out at the fires coming at you
they had seen people not get out great
gridlock and cars ain't moving and I
just it's the worst feeling ever
these people aren't getting out and
they're not traffic's not moving it was
it's hard the people that should have
been proud of what they had done to get
people out I think felt their own sense
of guilt that they hadn't been more
successful and that's a hard thing to to
have to live with at the house with the
yellow crime-scene tape just on the
inside was a statue of Jesus Christ to
me and it was such a representation in a
way of life and death to see it standing
there as if almost it was guarding over
what remained of that home there was a
sort of poignancy about that that these
statues had stayed but everything else
behind it had been destroyed
and then the sudden through the
viewfinder there's blackened beer
estudio were just standing there
completely shell-shocked and I'm you
know obviously trying to be still that's
fine image to see I didn't run away it
was like seriously confused animals I
kind of felt the same way of staged and
at that point we've been breathing in a
lot of smoke it was kind of jarring to
see life suddenly to live things and
that's all of the all of the death
really
[Music]
first day we went to paradise it was
like a ghost town
we were almost taken aback by just how
much access you know we were allowed but
the next day when we returned the tone
had changed remarkably
and I think the arrival of these people
who saw in white water suits was a big
change in the dynamic yeah those were
people who keep our distance you know
they really didn't want us to be with
them understood well we're just like you
do you think their job was to start
looking for bodies
it was a very heavy day and then it got
heavier and heavier and heavier well it
is a very grisly task as you can imagine
we're joining officers who are now going
through the building here that they've
identified me to be searched but you're
not seen bodies anymore
you're seeing fragments of bodies
because the heat had literally
incinerated everything
[Music]
the looks on the emergency services
faces had changed
[Music]
these are all homes and they've all got
to be looked at they have to go through
this process of looking for human
remains
they say it'll take as long as it takes
it has to be done properly and with
respect that they have to do it
literally inch by edge
[Music]
almost 19,000 homes were destroyed in
the fire
imagine how long it would take for them
to go through every building they'd
built their homes and their lives in an
area that then got decimated in a matter
of hours it was probably one of the
scariest experiences I've ever had there
was flames on both sides on the roads
you know there's five kids in the car
and I'm like wondering if we're gonna
die within three hours the entire town
was on fire I saw the smoke I text I
said you need get out yeah we made it
out and we're alive people in the
community had brought donations clothes
soft toys for the kids
almost everybody there had a horror
story could you see the fire was it
around you yes and others people ended
up getting where the cars were running
from the flames and a lot of people bag
it gone through the various emotions
sort of absolute fear then elation
debate survived and then guilt the
decisions that they had to make so I'm
going to tell you they're like four
years old and their parents are out of
gas and things like that you don't know
what happened how do you process that
there's a lot of little people up there
they didn't have time they don't even
know no missile 613 morning started by
8:30
it's engulfing paradise these people
weren't even licked yet you know and
they're back in the woods and you know I
just type here the word for and it just
yeah
nobody would know is a tragedy how do
you heal as a as a community where do
you start
it's very easy to be in Malibu and talk
about Gerard Butler or Miley Cyrus or
the Kardashians or Neil Young affected
by the fires but no one's really gonna
remember you know Rachel and Caleb and
their five children
[Music]
we'll paradise be rebuilt probably yes
is it wise to rebuild paradise exactly
where it is the likelihood is that
another fire will come through we should
be thinking about yes being aware of how
we're contributing to a changing climate
but also be aware of where we're
building our communities
[Music]
humans are so resilient we build up
war-torn countries all the time clearly
what happened in California will
fundamentally change planning when we
were in paradise the campfire was only
20 percent contained 20 percent it had
already you're brought utter destruction
to Paradise and the surrounding
communities but that it was only 20
percent contained the two fires were so
enormous so powerful actually mankind
couldn't stop in the end when we spoke
to firefighters in Paradise they said it
hadn't rained for 212 days but that the
rain would be the thing that would
hopefully bring both the campfire and
woolsey fires turn in those type of fire
storms can only be put out by now the
nature itself where the weather changes
the winds cool the rain comes and it
runs out of things to burn
[Music]